(crowd cheering)
- So you've met everybody now,
and you can also have
some wine if you'd like.
- Why are you guys so far away from me?
- This is about you and not us.
- Oh no!
(Chrissy laughs)
- Okay but yes thank you, cheers to that.
- [Kelly] Cheers fine, I'm a real friend,
I'm not gonna leave you hanging.
Oh now I feel like I have
to clink before I do it
or bad luck or something so.
(CL laughs)
- Okay, so you were just 12
when you started performing,
that's crazy.
- Yes.
- Like, how has life changed
since then obviously?
Was it kinda crazy hard when you were 12?
- I mean, I don't
remember much before that.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- You know?
12, 10.
- [Kelly] You know what, I don't either.
When people ask about your
child- I don't remember a lot.
- Do you remember when you were like 11?
- Not really.
- Yeah.
- Big moments.
- Moments, the ones that
you maybe write songs about.
- Yeah, yeah, yes.
- So what kind of music
did you grow up with?
- I grew up listening to actually,
a lot of powerful female
artists, including you obviously.
The first album I bought
was Lauryn Hill's album.
- [Kelly] Miss Educational.
- Yes.
(audience claps)
- Classic.
- That was one of my favorite too.
- I bought that for myself and you know,
Beyonce's first album,
Erica Badu, Missy Elliott,
Lil' Kim.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yes, very strong women.
- I know you like a strong
woman, I like that too,
that's cool.
Me too, I love it.
What did you grow up with in
Mexico city, what was real big
whenever you were growing up?
- Pop music.
We have a lot of influence
from the US, a lot.
But we also here like my actual wife,
she's a pop singer in Mexico.
- So you gotta say her
then, don't not say her.
- Say what? Her.
(crowd laughs)
- This is the cue where you say her.
- Her, her, Alessandra Rosaldo.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's so
cool, that's awesome.
- What did you listen to growing up?
- Everything, girl everything.
- Me too.
- I mean Lauryn Hill to
the Fugees to like Motown-
- [Kelly] Annie Lennox.
- Yeah, everyone and everyone.
- [Kelly] Aretha.
- Everyone, yeah.
- Yeah, I feel like we
had like such cool people
when we were younger to
listen to, I don't know.
Does everybody feel
like that? I don't know.
Well, John Malcovich is on
your album I find it crazy.
What kind of happenstance was that,
that he ended up on your album?
- So Pete Berg invited me
to be a part of his movie
called Mile 22.
And we were acting together and you know,
whatever time off we had,
he was just talking about
his stories from theater,
and connected, and he's
my mentor now here.
- [Kelly] I love that.
(crowd claps)
He's like one of my favorite actors.
- He is the best, he is.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And this is even more random,
is it true that Mike Tyson
was an inspiration for this album?
- [Girl] Yes.
- [Kelly] Please tell me how.
- [CL] You know, he's doing
these podcasts these days.
I'm a fan of him to start with-
- [Kelly] Oh I didn't know that.
- Yeah and I was just
going through his podcast
and some of the things he said,
things like before I fight,
how he feels, I connected to that.
- Oh.
(CL laughs)
- Do you see the stage as a boxing arena?
- You know, I think it's
just about the gap between,
you know, the emotions you
use on stage and off stage.
- Yeah, do you kind of become,
my mother was laughs at me
because she's like, I can tell it's like,
literally right when I finished the song,
then I become like the
bubbly me off stage.
- Yes.
- But during the song,
I'm like very in the zone,
you're like that as well.
- Yes.
- We all have a Sasha fierce.
- We all do and that's what
Alpha is about, my album so-
- [Kelly] I love that, that's
why you titled it that?
- Yes.
- I love that, is that where
you feel the most powerful?
Like in-
- [CL] On stage.
- Yeah.
- I'm a performer, so that's
where I feel comfortable.
And that's what I love doing.
- Yeah, I love your vibe,
I was watching while I
was getting ready today
and I was watching
rehearsals and I was like,
oh my god-
- You did?
- [Kelly] I did, I was
watching and I was like,
oh my gosh, and all the
dancer- it's so cool,
it's very, very cool.
- [CL] I had fun doing it.
- And I love it too, 'cause
it starts off in you're like,
I don't want to ruin it anyway.
I like the whole performance.
But speaking of like
how artistic you looked,
you went to the Met Gala this
year, was that so much fun?
- I love playing dress up so I had fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh you enjoy it?
(crowd cheers)
- Yes, I love doing it.
- [Kelly] By the way, I'm from Texas,
so this is so, Texas.
This is like how Texas-
- The theme was Americana so yes,
that's why there was
the jeans and you know,
I was wearing underwear.
- I love-
(Kelly laughs)
Good for you.
- [CL] I was-
- Good for you.
(CL and Kelly laugh)
- No, that was a part of the dress.
- But it was cool because I heard
it was an Asian designer, right?
- Yes, it was Alexander Wang,
and you know, it did not look
like that in the beginning,
but I wanted to make sure
I melt my culture in there.
So, we had to change it in 24 hours.
He made a completely new dress and the bow
is actually a traditional Korean, yeah.
- That's cool though, I
think that's my favorite
kind of art to where it's like,
you do take something that somebody makes,
but then you personalize it.
- [CL] Yes.
- Like people covering songs.
That's like my favorite thing they do.
- That's where the magic happens I think.
- [Kelly] That's so cool, I
love that you're into it all,
that's cool.
Well, you're performing
your song, Lover Like Me,
so what's that one about
other than maybe possibly
being a lover like you?
(Kelly laughs)
- Well it's, you know,
I'm just talking to my ex.
- [Kelly] Oh I love that.
- Telling him you will never,
ever find a lover like me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(crowd cheers)
- I love that kind of
empowering statement.
Especially if you're like after a breakup,
so many people are going
to relate to that message.
- Yeah I was just like you know,
when you're brushing it off.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Listen to that song,
you'll be like, yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yes.
- I love you.